hallo liebe freundin liebe yoga
schwester wie schön dass du dir heute
zeit nimmst wird dich aber auch für mich
zu meinem onlinekurs entspannung mit
elke heute möchte ich dich zu einer
entspannungsübung einladen die sofort
akuten stress abbaut und uns frauen beim
täglichen spagat zwischen beruf und
familie wieder in die richtige balance
bringt also
schließe deine augen
suche dir eine bequeme sitzposition die
schultern sind gerade
atmen noch einmal tief ein und wenn du
so weit bist dann sprich mir einfach
nach
[Musik]
was aus eurem zimmer macht eure
trefferpunkte völlig alleine und europas
stärken überlässt aber auch rein wo du
fauler hund schreibt ich heute wieder
halb zu deinem freund dem etwas essen
willst du das aber scharapowa stadt eine
dritte nordhausen gefälligst selber
haben und später verstößt das butterbrot
ich persönlich mache diese übung
mehrmals und bei mir tritt die
entspannung sofort darauf ein also
genießen noch einmal die ruhe solange
die familie noch in einer hab acht
stellung ist also besonders achtsam ist
wie umarme dich und freue mich aufs
nächste mal wenn es heißt entspannung
mit ihren
namen
[Applaus]
da seit sie damaligen für roboter wie
lange dauert die kamera